hello freak [ __ ] it is very cold like
and again you know the you asked me what
would have to happen for us to to right
the ship the second one is that my
faculty colleagues have to wake up to
the fact that their belief structure is
has become bizarre and unrecognizable
from any normal position and very
dangerous in the perspective of an
educator if this is what an educated
person who has gone through the entire
system and now has a job in educating
young people if this is how you view the
world and this is how you view facts and
this is how you distort them and then
disseminate them to the rest of these
like-minded folks in this very bizarre
echo chamber that's being rejected it's
like almost universally outside of the
the college I mean it's not just FoxNews
it's rejecting it's the Washington Post
it's the New York Times they people are
freaking out about your situation and
recognize very clearly and very rightly
that you are absolutely not a racist
right and this is the this kind of a lot
of what I've said to Jordan Peterson
when I had him on like they [ __ ] with
the wrong person again they [ __ ] with
the wrong person and this is one of the
most horrific things about what I find
so troubling about what I think of as I
used to think of myself as a progressive
but what I prop what I have a problem
with all of this is that the left is
attacking itself now it's like it's it's
there's no one who's progressive enough
no one like every single thing you do is
a microaggression every single thing you
do is based on white privilege and
therefore you're racist and unless you
somehow another give up all your money
and give up all your jobs and there are
people who are asking to do that too by
the way because people asking people to
give their money and put them in black
banks give them to black people I mean
we're going crazy that this is this is
literally it's not an individual
psychosis but it's a collective
psychosis that we're watching and I
believe that in literal terms we are
watching a kind of group insanity this
is a problem with language
is in some ways is this there's a
problem with influence and charisma and
people's ability to sort of change the
way others view the world with dramatic
interpretations of events and and things
like emails where this is not a
one-on-one debate there's a real problem
with blogs and emails and I've talked
about this several times but it's it's
worth repeating there's a real problem
when someone writes something like that
specifically about another person like
you and just writes it but you're not
there to respond so they can write as
much stuff that's not true and they can
put it all down and then it's there and
then someone has to refute it but it's
still there so you don't even get to
refute the actual document you write
your own and then someone has to go and
read that at a different location it's a
real weird way to distribute information
and it's contrary to the way human
beings rationally discuss and debate
ideas well I would say there are many
rules that are written into the way we
interact now that make it possible for
this to happen so there was a instance
where a faculty member
accused those that were challenging any
of these equity proposals as being part
of a racist backlash and she was clearly
talking about me because I'm the most
the most prominent person objectives
faculty member a white person unknown so
anyway she says in a faculty meeting
that this is a racist backlash and I
said to her in front of this faculty
meeting I said somebody might want to
check on the question of whether or not
I'm actually a racist because if you do
check on it you will discover I'm not
and if you don't this is going to blow
up on you and the chair of the faculty
told me that the faculty meeting was not
the place to defend myself against
accusations of racism I said to her
that's fine
where is oh not the place to lovely yeah
right to level the accusations but I
said where is the place and then the
faculty member who had made the
accusations said you should not expect
there to be a venue in which to defend
yourself you should just get used to
these accusations
a separate case I was quiet who said
that why Kyra it's the same faculty
member who made the accusation wait a
minute the person said that you should
just accept these untrue accusations yes
yeah I mean was your reaction to that
that this is not a place for you to
defend yourself against racist
accusations this is a place for you to
just eat [ __ ] right you just have to
accept you values on a separate occasion
we were also told that that to question
an allegation of racism is racist
oh so convenient around that one to
question an accusation of racism is
racist right we have an obligation to
believe Wow I know I know
wait a minute how that's crazy that is
like that is such stupid back-ass words
thinking it you know it's it's what the
cult mentality sounds like inside it
doesn't understand that when you say
that to an outsider you know it simply
doesn't add up or it's creating a
structure that makes it impossible to
defend yourself because these
accusations are so preposterous that
they realize they have to have some sort
of a bizarro world structure absolutely
oh my god so where's this person teach
they teach media so they tell Roenick
right they teach media they are
currently running a program where she's
teaching students to make documentaries
and that program one of the students in
the program filed a public records
request since we are a public college
you can request the emails of faculty
and staff if you want them and so she
had a student file a public records
request from my email to make a
documentary in her program so you've got
one faculty member searching and other
faculty members email through a student
looking for evidence of I don't know
what but evidence of racism well
presumably oh god yes what
a half of a sentence she's going to cut
out a contest with a few drivers I mean
in fact if you can separate my letters
from each other and reorganize them I
could have said all kinds of thing well
I think you should have a student ask
for the emails that came from her I bet
they'd be wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]